okay
i have a theory
you guys know what this means man you
guys know what this means when i say
i have a theory i have an idea
this is gonna i think this is really
really cool and i wanna know what you
guys think about it right building off
the the video that we did yesterday at
the time that we're making this video
when we did the trailer breakdown for
the super bowl trailer for doctor
strange 2. one of the things we talked
about was this idea that wanda was like
a universal constant right really a
multiversal constant in every single
universe there's always a wanda who
always becomes a scarlet witch we'll
circle back around to that here in a
minute here's the thing about the
illuminati and we'll make a separate
video where i run over who i think the
different members of the illuminati are
because right now with the exception of
charles xavier whose voice we heard no
one's confirmed right so no matter what
anybody tells you until the marvel
cinematic universe comes out and gives
us a trailer where it's like here's the
illuminati no one knows for sure right
it's just speculating and so having said
that the first question we really have
to ask here is who brought the
illuminati together right see in the
comics the illuminati came together they
i mean you could largely assume they
existed in alternate realities and in
fact they did we know that from
hickman's avengers new avengers but they
only came together because of like the
collapse of the multiverse that's the
only time we saw them
unify we assume they existed before that
but we don't really know why but in the
main marvel universe of marvel comics
which is the only real basis that we
have the illuminati came together
because of the creed scroll war right
this war between the cree and the scroll
that almost destroyed earth and that the
different members of the superhero
community right so like professor xavier
of the x-men and iron man and reed
richards the fantastic four and black
panther and black fole of the inhumans
and all these guys they all had
information that if they had shared
would have kept the kree scroll war from
coming as close to earth as it did and
so they basically formed in order to
operate behind the scenes in order to
ensure that like nothing like that would
ever happen again kind of a fun fact
here this is an important thing black
panther was not originally part of the
illuminati in fact he actually turned
down the offer to join the team and he
told them this is a terrible idea and
it's never going to work but i feel like
that's kind of important but to me
there's only two possibilities of who it
was that brought the illuminati together
the first one is like a version of
doctor strange likely defender doctor
strange
who brought them all together realizing
what was happening across the multiverse
with regards to wanda the second
possibility here is reed richards of the
fantastic four and the reason why i say
that it is also possible that it's baron
mordo right one thing to keep in mind is
that the barren murder that we see in
doctor strange too looks like the baron
mordo from doctor strange one he keeps
talking about how like there's
consequences and like the bill comes due
which like he just wouldn't shut up
about in the first doctor strange movie
so you know it basically seems like it
is the exact same guy like this is what
he's been doing all this time but the
reason why i choose these guys i really
choose these two possibilities is
because if you look at the trailer for
doctor strange too what it looks like is
a movie that follows the relationship
between doctor strange and the scarlet
witch not in the the interpersonal
relationship which it made very well
dive into that but the relationship
between the two in terms of like how
they use their powers and what they're
capable of and that defender strange may
have basically figured out what was
going on and in turn says like we need
to form the illuminati because of that
now i'll talk about what that means here
in a minute you know once we kind of get
around to the final part of this video
i'll wrap back around to that and it'll
make more sense with reid richards this
is a less likely possibility but a
possibility nonetheless one of the
hallmarks of reed and the fantastic four
is the fact that they explore the
multiverse they travel to other
universes and we see other things in
those alternate universes and in fact
reed has experimented with the
multiverse a couple times the first one
which you talked about before was the
council of reeds which was basically
alternate reality versions of reed
richardson the fantastic four who gave
up their families all for the purpose of
solving the problem of everything right
just like figuring out ways to fix the
multiverse so where they were like whole
universes where people were like
starving on different worlds and things
like that because you know uh any number
of reasons that what the council of
reeds did is they actually used
basically other realities where there
was no life or no sentient life anyway
and would literally harvest entire
worlds by growing like crops and things
like that and then feed other universes
it's just kind of crazy right it's like
one state feeding another state here in
america except you're talking about
whole universes uh reid has also formed
what was called the bridge which allowed
him to see into alternate realities so
it's entirely possible that reed saw
what we're going to be talking about
here in a little while and said oh my
god something needs to be done again a
much less likely idea here but it also
makes sense that it's possible there uh
now the other part that really comes
here is why did these guys come together
right is it that each of their universes
were destroyed is it that like their
earths were destroyed and honestly this
is where i think we circle around to the
idea that wanda is the reason why it all
happened that what we're basically
talking about here is the destruction of
realities not in the traditional sense
we're not talking about whole universes
blowing up what we're talking about are
whole universes being absorbed so one
thing to keep in mind i actually went
back and i watched uh some of the really
the the tail end of doctor strange uh
one and then i went back and i watched
uh the scene with wandavision where you
had like the conversation between wanda
and agatha as lengthy as that was in the
few moments in between remember one of
the things that agatha said is that
wanda is destined to become the scarlet
witch we also know that she was
described as a nexus being but basically
wanda is destined to become that person
it would stand to reason that wanda
would become that person seemingly in
every reality there's no reason to
believe that wouldn't be the case the
fact that we're talking about like this
darkhold book right that basically spans
not simply just a single universe but
across the multiverse that wanda is
destined to become the scarlet witch in
every single reality now here's where
things get really cool right so in the
scene in the trailer with a little world
illusion right the the energy that's put
off by doctor strange that looks like
little worlds and stuff you know we'll
put it up here on the screen so you guys
can see it that looks like the
manifestation of the dark dimension in
hong kong and doctor strange one right
the scene where like mordo and doctor
strange jump through the portal because
dr strange is like i really need your
help and then once they get there like
basically the dark dimension starts to
manifest on earth it looks exactly like
that right one of the other things to
know is that wanda is in possession of
the dark hold which is made from energy
from the dark dimension we know that
from the runaways from agents of shield
and from one division itself right i
mean we've largely been assuming that
like cathode or somebody is a part of it
largely just because of the comic book
basis but there's been nothing to
indicate that's the case cathone's name
has never been mentioned in any aspect
of the marvel cinematic universe we're
literally just taking comic book
knowledge and running with it as an
absolute truth because there's been
nothing to say otherwise but maybe
that's not the case maybe there is no
catholic there is no mephisto or
anything like that right the realm of
dormammu is oftentimes referred to as
the hell dimension right like it is the
dark dimension it's what you would
consider to be a hell-like place one
other thing to keep in mind and this is
huge right
dormammu didn't know anything about time
he had never experienced time until dr
strange showed up and doctor strange won
and like the whole like door mom who
have come to bargain thing right so he
introduced time to dormammu and one of
the things that baron mordo kept saying
is you've broken the laws like the
magical laws of the cosmos right you
were not supposed to do that you did not
defeat dormammu by basically constantly
looping time until he was just sort of
baffled and confused and then in order
to escape it made a bargain with you and
turned kaiselius and those guys into the
mindless ones what you did is you gave
him a tool he didn't have before right
now that dormammu is in possession of
time seemingly anything is a possibility
now and so what i would argue here right
what i would present here as this theory
that i'm putting forward in this video
is that in effect
wanda
is basically being controlled or at
least possessed or seemingly became a
vessel for dormammu instead of cathone
that using the darkhold but not knowing
what she's messing with specifically
after the events of wand division that
wanda is overtaken by dormammu which
allows him to seize control of her
universe and then absorb it into the
dark dimension likely killing her in the
process this explains a lot if this is
true right it explains all the different
demonic type beings that we've seen
because we know that like you know
during the events or really even before
the events of doctor strange one that
duramamu's realm the dark dimension
already consisted of places that he had
already conquered we didn't know what
was there we simply just knew it was
already realities out there that he had
overtaken maybe there was more than one
hell dimension and then he basically
just conquered it and now it all exists
under him directly this would also
explain why shimogorath has all those
runes that are basically all over him
another part of this is that the
darkhold which again is made from dark
dimension energy specifically has a
whole chapter devoted to the scarlet
witch it's not that outside the realm of
possibility to believe that wanda using
chaos magic is basically mainlining the
power of dormammu literally channeling
his power directly and that the more she
uses the dark hold the more she allows
it to basically become a part of her the
more of herself that she basically dumps
into the dark hole by virtue of using it
because one of the things we know from
like runaways and agents of shield all
that kind of stuff is the longer you
have that book in your possession the
more that book will begin to dominate
you it's entirely possible that her
having no idea what she's doing that's
how dormammu gets sent and when that
happens he basically overtakes her
absorbs the entire universe destroys the
universe and the members of the
illuminati that we see are the last
surviving members of those universes
they're basically the only ones who made
it out right they were basically rounded
up or they were they were brought
together by uh maybe defender strange he
was like okay so basically dormammu is
expanding the dark dimension because
some idiot out there basically gave him
knowledge of how time works and in doing
so he knows when wanda is going to
become the scarlet witch he knows when
that's going to take place he knows when
and where to manipulate her like her
hearing the voices of her kids and then
basically luring her in and seizing
control of her and basically using her
as a vessel right like she's literally
possessed and then through her taking
over the entirety of the universe
because remember wanda's power exceeds
that of the sorcerer supreme basically
what this indicates is wanda at her peak
is the most powerful person in the
universe it's not that outside the realm
of possibility that if she really is
mainlining the power of dormammu with
chaos magic that in turn he uses that
basically takes her over she becomes the
full embodiment of dormammu's power and
then dormammu conquers everything right
thermometer just like takes all that
over so literally the illuminati are not
some kind of you know multiversal group
that's basically overseeing everything
kind of similar to the tva
they're basically refugees right that's
really all it is and maybe it's not
simply just them right maybe they're
like the leaders of this big kind of
illuminati citadel but there's just tons
of refugees out there right tons of
people who manage to escape their
realities different things like that
that in those scenes when you see like
america chavez right when you had like
the bands of cedar actually basically
freaking out or something like that or
that that was a universe which was
basically conquered by dormammu i mean
even looking at that thing it does feel
reminiscent of dormammu right the
coloring the energy it puts off all that
kind of stuff right it would also be
really interesting if basically it
turned out that like defender strange
was a member of the illuminati and
basically he's dead now and so when
steven strange from like the marvel
cinematic universe shows up they invite
him to replace like defender strange so
he ends up becoming a member of the
illuminati right that's one of the
things that a lot of people are talking
about out there right now so that's not
really my original idea uh but i think
this is entirely possible here right
that it really is all because of wanda
and maybe it's one of those things where
like in every single universe dr strange
tries to stop her and doctor strange
always fails right the idea of like some
west view-esque event always happens
that wanda always becomes a scarlet
witch and wanda always meddles with the
dark hole now here's the real question
right if you guys really want to go down
the rabbit hole with me here let's let's
let's let's get a little crazy on this
theory right let's really get a little
bonkers here
here's a question you have to ask if
that's always the case then why is it
only now that it's becoming a problem
i would say it's because sylvie killed
he who remains she killed immortus right
that in previous instances when wanda
would basically go through that the west
view esque event whatever form that
happened to take she would get her hands
on the dark hole and then like dormammu
would basically try to seize control of
her the tva would show up snatch her up
and take her away and that would be the
end of it but there is no tva now right
remember like the scene where wanda
becomes a scarlet witch directly
coincides in the moment when uh when
basically he who remains a mortise or
whatever says like we've crossed the
threshold right the guy knew his fate
was sealed he knew it was all said and
done that there was no coming back from
this and that when that happened and he
was basically killed there is no one to
grab the scarlet witch there isn't one
to stop us to snap her up there's no one
to stop her from becoming a vessel for
dermamu thereby preventing dormammu from
expanding the power or expanding the
dark dimension across the multiverse and
now he's basically just kind of
expanding out right just growing over
and over and over again and that's
basically it right literally conquering
universe after universe after universe
right again rabbit hole stuff right i
mean that seems really far-fetched even
though it does sound kind of cool but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section right i mean you
guys think this is just like a
ridiculous theory there's no way it's
true it just sounds absolutely stupid or
do you think it has some credibility to
it and as always which i know i don't
have to ask you guys to do poke holes in
this theory right i mean i know i don't
have to ask you guys for that you guys
are you guys poke holes in theories no
matter what what it comes up with you
know it's you know it's it's just your
all's thing right you guys love being
like rob you're wrong right it's
definitely black panther on the
illuminati we don't know that it is i
just want it to be so i'm going to treat
my opinion as fact
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments uh thank you all for
watching i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]